transatlantique en solitaire et bien on
commence à rentrer dans le brouillard au
propre et au figuré
nous aimerions bien chaque jour vous
donner la position exacte des
concurrents mais ce ne sera pas facile
pardon pourtant théoriquement chaque
bateau est relié à plymouth et doit
faire son point quotidiennement mais
certains paraît-il triche pour ne pas
avantager leurs adversaires alors ce
soir nous avons décidé de mener notre
propre enquête
comme les bateaux ne sont pas encore
très éloignée des côtes en régaler à
survoler en avion la tête de la course
voici donc un point précis avec une
seule incertitude la place de tabari
vendredi 13 avec ils ont reconnu devant
le catamaran de joris terrain qui est à
6 km environ proviennent le voilier
géant d'alain colas à près de 15
kilomètres de terre il n'a pas été
possible de citer eric tabarly près
semblablement ce dernier suit une route
nord et il est sans doute en tête de la
course car la direction du vent avantage
son bateau qui marche très bien auprès
le concurrent avec qui nous avons pu
communiquer par radio alain colas
écouter dû retourner dans l'est avec
l'arrivée des trois ans et prend l'air
et c'est bel et bien comme leur part que
vous éprouvez par laboeuf le téléthon
quand je vais lui parler de vision
lalart les efforts demain téléphonique
soit mieux qu'aux pelouses devant la
passe et le bruit on y voit plus grand
soin à brouiller un peu les joies casque
avec pas mal de bosses ou des bons des
moins bons mais ces produits
l'adage bien compris d'après ce dialogue
que notre pilote le capitaine les
tarides la base de lann bihoué ne
voulait pas de données de position très
précise alain colas est contraire au
règlement